have you ever dealt with cockroaches in
the uk at all because
like i remember like for most of my life
i i had just never seen a cockroach
because
like the uk is pretty clean in terms of
imagine the privilege of living in a
in a sanitary home cockroaches what is
that
i saw a fair amount when i moved to
london but oh really in wales i didn't
see many
yeah because i remember my my very first
cockroach experience was actually not in
the uk but it was in thailand
right and i remember because like my
house is not like in the city center
it's like
right on the outskirts and we're near
like a lot of like uh
like not not a forest but like a lot of
like grassland basically so
we're we're like right out in the
outskirts of the city
so we're like right next to nature as
well so some of the cockroaches we find
are pretty massive right and at this
point
i was living in thailand with sydney and
it was just me and sydney in the house
right
and so i was just sitting in my living
room just chilling out
and i hear this [ __ ] guttural scream
coming from sydney right
she's like i had never heard sydney like
sydney's already a loud person as is but
i had no
no no but i had never heard this kind of
scream from sydney i was just like
i thought she just witnessed the [ __ ]
murder or something right that's that's
the kind of screaming
yeah so i come rushing over thinking
that something serious something bad has
happened
and i just see this [ __ ] massive
cockroach just chilling in our kitchen
floor
but yeah how big are we talking okay so
it was about it was about that big
okay it was a chunky [ __ ] how
much bigger does it need to get bro
starts [ __ ] talking
that's the point it was terraforming
yeah yeah yeah because because the way
the [ __ ] creatures get in because our
kitchen is pretty clean but because
we're right on the outskirts right
near the forest and everything so
sometimes they can like crawl up the
drains
and like come out from out come out from
under the trees i didn't know this i
only found out
about this afterwards because my first
thought was [ __ ] i thought our kitchen
is clean [ __ ]
burned the entire house down and
everything right but this was my first
time
stealth mission
and like i don't know how you guys are
with bugs i'm sure you'll find joey
because you're australian
like for me i'm not i'm not like a
massive fan of bugs you know
i like i don't enjoy i mean i mean i'm
not a fan
i'm not a fan of having to deal with
them but some people can just like
[ __ ] grab the bugs or whatever i'm
just like
no i'll i'll do like the cup method
where you know you see a spider you like
cup
it and uh put a piece of paper in it and
just let it out i don't enjoy it
i'm not i'm not like i'm not like scared
but i'm not i don't enjoy
doing it
you know when there's people who like
[ __ ] grab the spiders and are like
oh what do you mean you're scared i
don't want to [ __ ] grab the spider
why would i want to grab the spot even
if even if i don't like
hate this thing yeah why the [ __ ] would
i want to have it wriggling around in my
you uh the method that my dad uses to
get rid of we'll do that afterwards
[ __ ] sucks in his mouth
son but yeah because because because me
and sydney are
a couple because she's like i i feel
like when you're in a couple
the one who's least scared is the one
that deals with the power of course of
course and of course
it was me i wasn't happy about it but i
was just like sydney you're you just
you you you look like you just witnessed
like a murder whatever
get out of the way i guess as the man
i guess as the man of the house here i
will take care of the cockroach i know i
had to do it
and i was thinking this was going to be
easy right the cockroach was big you
know
and i didn't know that much about
cockroaches at the time
so
so i thought this is going to be an easy
because we had like literally we had
a cockroach spray and i was thinking all
i need to do
is get the spray spray the cockroach job
done
it dies i sweep it out the house yeah
easy right
now so i get the spray and there are
there are
two pieces of information that i didn't
know about cockroaches before i did this
number one cockroaches are very very
hard to kill
yes and i knew this
but i thought it's a spray designed to
kill cockroaches
therefore in my mind instant death you
know that's that's how it's worked my
entire life
right number two cockroaches can fly
yeah i did not know this either some
species are all of them
i think all of them can fly i've never
seen a cockroach fly i mean they gotta
they have to be pretty [ __ ]
like yeah gtfo mode yeah yeah
i did not know they could fly either so
it was just like crawling around the
floor
it was like terraforming oh yeah it's
literally telling it's like literally
the last resort for these
so i'm just like sydney get out of the
way let the man of the house handle this
and so i get the spray out get pretty
close to it
and i just give it a nice little love
tap of a spray
and what happens it starts freaking the
[ __ ] out
right yeah i'm just like what the [ __ ]
is happening right and then i spray even
more
and then i just hear that
[Music]
you know the sound where you just hear
the wings flapping and then it starts
flapping
and then it flies and lands on my chest
and then i counter attack and then
i'm in [ __ ] flight or a fight or
flight mode now
i uh and then i [ __ ] scream as loud
as i've like screamed in my life before
i think i
i i'm not ashamed to admit how [ __ ]
loud i screamed
five minutes after i've just told sydney
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
let me handle this i brush it off like i
[ __ ]
leg it out of the kitchen and i just
like locked the kitchen right
and i could hear i could hear like the
cockroach just like freaking out in the
kitchen
[Music]
i've seen that cindy just turns around
and goes did you do it what's what's
going on and i'm just like just don't go
in that kitchen
and like me and sydney were just like we
were just like
we were just like in the living room we
could just hear this cockroach for the
entire night just freaking out and
we were just like oh god are we gonna
have to burn the entire house down it'll
get bored
yeah he'll get it it'll get bored
eventually cockroach spray is the
biggest [ __ ]
lie on the planet i feel like aren't
cockroaches the only animals that can
like survive a nuclear blast i don't
know
like that so it's like what is in these
sprays that is supposedly
stronger than a nuclear blast
that's why i like i don't stop until it
stops moving i'm like i'm like
you know apex aim yeah following it
around the room yeah i thought that
would be fine as well like i said i
didn't know they could fly that was the
big
oh they could fly this is the the rules
of the game have changed now they can
counter attack you now
normally i spray them just so that
they're stunned for a second so i can
[ __ ] smack them yeah
well i mean i don't i don't like doing
that because then it leaves like a mark
yeah yeah and also it's not a guaranteed
kill
unless you're using unless you're using
like a [ __ ] heavy helicopter
joe joe what's your kda with cockroaches
yeah you grab like a
sushi right because the sole of the suit
shoes are very firm very flat you can
just like [ __ ]
clap them on yeah